[Music]
you
hey everybody what's up so by popular
demand you requested a Cersei night king
white Walker video there's a couple
other things we need to talk about like
zombie Bride of Frankenstein explainer
for some of the evidence that the show
has given us for her potential path if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything I do Game of
Thrones videos every week so a lot of
you are asking about the Cersei breath
during that trailer so the big
prevailing theory now is that she could
potentially align herself with White
Walkers in the night King the most
obvious thing is it is just implying
that winter's coming for the rest of
Westeros all the way down in King's
Landing
look at the map here this is where the
wall is this is where the night king is
coming to sometime in season seven this
is how far he has to travel even though
the text has been very vague about the
association between the weather itself
like winter itself in the night king it
would still take a long time for it to
start snowing in King's Landing that
would be crazy but that's where we're
headed and officially the Citadel has
released the white Ravens that's what
Samwell was looking at when they first
arrived there that means that winter has
come they released the white Ravens they
send them to all the different castles
and say hey you know winters here the
season has officially changed but
Westeros is a big place is going to take
a long time to see visible signs of
winter all the way further south like in
the reach down in Dorne
it will not start snowing in the desert
overnight and there are so many things
that have to happen before Cersei would
choose the White Walkers over anyone
else in Westeros so the idea is that
she'd have to be backed into a corner I
think the idea of Cersei without her
children has pretty terrifying prospect
because it was the one thing that really
humanized her you know her love for her
kids and as much of a monster as she
could sometimes be she was a mother who
truly did love her children and now
those children are gone and all she's
got his power and she's got a lot of it
I mean she's the queen and she's sitting
on the Iron Throne
I only have bodes well for anyone really
and I think you know even for Jaime who
loves her I think it's a terrifying
moment
she's capable of doing anything as she's
proven in this episode to get what she
wants and the real question now is what
does she want
so let's chart this timeline we have
Daenerys alliance she's aligned with the
forces of the reach they control most of
the grain in the kingdom they can start
starving Cersei out Joran is still
available to take care of Daenerys bleed
so there are a couple of big battles
that have to happen before Daenerys can
actually make landfall and King's
Landing
because I think that's what we're all
waiting for but she's sort of on this
path mirroring Aegon the conquerors path
so she's still going to have to go
around and subdue all the other
loyalists to the crowd and that includes
the Lannisters of Casterly Rock which
are completely on the other side of
Westeros from King's Landing
Daenerys promised to help with Joran
Greyjoy he has a massive fleet so what
they could do is try to intercept him on
the western coast here that would get
then to Casterly Rock so that's where
you get your Lannister battle but
remember they'd have to go around the
reach down here down around old town
Samwell Tarly father was one of the
greatest generals that the Mad King had
he is old school so it's more than
likely that he would support the crown
but even if the Tyrells have problems
with them it seems like most of Westeros
will wind up aligning against Cersei the
only thing the Lannisters have going for
them is their gold and in the books it's
implied that the gold mines are running
dry so they get backed into a corner
that's where you start to see Cersei
making plans to possibly align with the
knight King the only way that makes
sense is if she goes completely scorched
earth policy although that metaphor
works a little better for Daenerys
because dragons literally scorched the
earth but if they haven't been very
clear about it on the show in the books
as she's heading up to her walk of shame
that's sort of where they end her book
storyline they've already gone way past
her book plot on the TV show but as
she's getting ready for the walk of
shame she's slowly and slowly descending
into more madness the people around her
start to question her sanity she gets
more and more paranoid so even if she
winds up doing the same thing during
winds of winter and blows up the faith
militant before her trial using wildfire
it's still implied that she's descending
into madness leaving septa unella in the
hands of the zombie mountain seems like
the most vicious thing ever so what
they're trying to show you what TV
Cersei is that she seems like she has a
together and she has a plan but really
she will not hesitate to kill her
subjects she just blew up a whole bunch
of them with wild fire at the end of
last season so it's not too hard to buy
that she would align with the enemy of
her enemies
so you see Jon Snow you kind of hope
he'll come to his senses there's one
more that matters it's coming for all of
us we have to stop it
so the burden of proof is on him now
Daenerys doesn't know anything about it
but she has enough sensible people
around her giving her advice like Tyrion
and Varys that they would tell her of
the threat of the night king in the
White Walkers and she would do the right
thing so if you're just talking about
books or see I would have never thought
that she would ever become a white
Walker or become a supposed bride of the
knight King but the really cool thing
about that theory is that it does not
trample on the valonqar someone still
gets to kill her
whether it be Jaime or Arya or someone
else I really want it to be Jaime just
because that would be so poetic but that
would still leave the door open for her
to be resurrected so she gets to be this
badass character just completely
destroying everything in her path during
season seven still gets to die and show
up and be a badass character during
season a because Alina HEDIS contract
does go through season eight but that
doesn't mean that she's going to live
through season eight the only way around
that technicality is to become a risen
white Walker yourself or be risen in the
way that Jon Snow was brought back by
Melisandre so let me know in the
comments pie-in-the-sky Theory do you
want to see Cersei turned into a white
Walker and work with the night king
during season eight now there's so many
questions about what would actually
happen to logistics of it was she retain
her mind who she becomes some soulless
minion they can talk their language is
called Schroth but it sounds like ice
cracking so we've been if a white Walker
Cersei gave the greatest speech ever we
wouldn't be able to understand what she
was saying and I should actually add the
Qyburn can also bring people back from
the dead - he seems very committed to
Cersei so that's just one more way that
she could come back
zombie Cersei that would be one of the
greatest villains during season eight
what do you think you're doing fading
hey yo Chris I wish it were otherwise
but Ser Gregor is beyond saving
well we're beyond this man not even a
maester let alone grand maester that's
- the best Westerners had to save him
that is exactly the sort of arrogance
but hurt him it
you can take him difficult to say right
but if I past work is any guide Stella
chance process may change so on that
weekend him oh no very well then may I
have the honor of presenting the newest
member of the Kingsguard
please your grace he has taken a holy
vow of silence
he swore that he will not speak until
all his Grace's enemies are dead and the
evil has been driven from the rim so let
me know in the comments what are all
your Searcy theories I know a lot of you
asked for a Dragonstone video because
Daenerys is in Dragonstone in the teaser
so I'll do a video for that in a couple
more days there's a new round of the
game of Thrones giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video it's for a copy of
one of the enhanced editions of the
books congratulations to the recent
winner for my last video Carlton
Matthews please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details while you wait for
that to post you can click here to
rewatch the trailer and you can click
here for my Stannis video thank you so
much for watching let's high five I'll
see you guys in the next video